ob er so richtig kräftig das jetzt nicht
aus wahrscheinlich muss das jetzt
einfach unter meinem mantel versteckt
halten irgendwie ich hoffe das geht
heute was gab jetzt willkommen beim
neuen video
heute ist krass gutes wetter draußen und
das wusste ich auch gestern schon und
ich habe sie schon ab und zu mal gesagt
meine haare sind wieder krass lang
geworden
ich muss unbedingt wieder zum friseur
und warum soll ich dafür geld ausgeben
wenn es auch kollege herr abschrift der
friseur ist so halb deswegen der kommt
gleich zu mir
die haben jetzt gerade moment ich muss
mal kurz gucken ich bin eben erst
aufgestanden 15 uhr
und er kommt am 17 ich muss auf jeden
fall noch kurzen die stadt was wichtiges
besorgt etwas wichtiges besorgen davor
gehen wir erst mal kurz im garten weil
er schalten wir im garten die haare
haben wir ein geber ich habe das so vor
weil kein bock in meinem zimmer das
alles weg legen zu müssen draußen fliegt
er von alleine weg legen kurz raus dann
erkläre ich euch meinen vorgehen und ich
hoffe es klappt aber es muss klappen und
keine ahnung ist auch scheißegal wir
werden sehen wie's warten wir gehen
essen runter
vorher mussten schnell diese
bananenschale entsorgen obst als keiner
gesehen
mama das war nicht okay leute jetzt bin
ich auf jeden fall im garten ist zu
michael ihr die vögel zwitschern
ja und zwar mein plan sieht wie folgt
aus chapter noch die lege er oben am
laden die es noch werden soll
die welt gleich manche kritik gleich
irgendwo hier in die spät gelegt ich
setze mich dann hier hin also die hätte
so ein weitwinkel das seht ihr dann auf
jeden fall sorgt jetzt ziemlich dann hin
und er scheint mir halt die haare und
ich muss jetzt noch ganz schön die stadt
unserem komisches spiel sagen geschäft
und zwar gibt's da ich hoffe die haben
die aber eigentlich schon so von
karneval noch diese diese blut kapseln
so kunstblut halt und wenn er mir die
haare scheidt und halt mit dem rasierer
so undercut mäßig sorgt 6 mm macht oder
so kann ich habe immer wieder machen ist
der sommer dann springe ich plötzlich so
auf habe vorher diese blut kapsel in
meiner hand gehabt damit teilt bluttat
an ihren und schreibe keine 8
und er denkt dann hoffe ich dass er mich
halt so übels geschnitten hat keine
ahnung ob es klappt aber können wir ja
mal versuchen genau ich bin gespannt
mal sehen und
gar nicht viel
hast du schon überall reck gemacht
gauleiter
kelly
junge leute ich weiß nich so scheiße aus
aber das wird noch gut hoffe ich auf
jeden fall
ich habe damit sie sie laden das letzte
kunstkompass noch gar keine ahnung
können auch wenn das ist schon
abgelaufen ist es ablaufen kann
wir machen das jetzt einfach um meine
hand und irgendwann machten halt einfach
so und dann blutet dass hier bald werden
wir sehen aber dass die klappen sieht
man dass gerade das einfach voll in
meinem hund gekommen okay
großen spaß
franken sich spies und operativ gut dass
jetzt nicht aus erscheint ich muss das
jetzt einfach unter dem mantel versteckt
halten irgendwie ich hoffe das geht ok
degen jetzt raus und ich hoffe das
klappt alles so wie ich es mir
vorgestellt habe
ich weiß nicht wie leute der die kamera
so gut versteckt dass bald wieder mal
gucken was da vor ort
leute sportfeste vorhat wieder was hast
du vor dir
wir können auch ein gemeint wenn anders
prenger stadt immer uns gegenseitig es
gibt schon so vieles
ich habe auch ich habe auch noch nicht
wieder überlegt ob ich dich bringen kann
oder sich einfach nichts ein
aber eigentlich ist ja auch nur wieder
dran
das immer so weiß ich nicht
ohne witz in diesem moment habe ich
einfach nichts mehr gecheckt
alle die alle fäusten net haben will
wir müssten das glaube ich jetzt kenne
ich nicht aber du mich nicht hast du
mich ja indirekt eigentlich wollte sogar
noch so ablenken und diesen so spreng
preis und so dass man anders krank
anstatt immer uns gegenseitig weißt du
aber leute eigentlich war die kamera gar
nicht mal so schlecht versteckt das
machen ich hab gedacht ich war nicht
darauf achten dass mit dem video ich
hoffe mein hase in wenigstens gut aus
dann gibt's hier nicht eine coole sache
heute könnt ihr aus trost hat sie nach
oben da passen
auch wenn ich schlecht bin wie ich bin
heute morgen bin ich aufgewacht oder
gestern abend hatte ich schon so eine
idee so weißt du und ich hatte nur das
blut nicht und dann ist mir die idee
gekommen dass du das in diesem geschäft
haben
ich bin extra er aufgestanden wegen dir
kann ich euch für man doch besseres
geben
erst da habe ich gar nein das kannst du
machen
ehrlichkeit wäre realistischer als dass
das fußballspiel wird egal ich habe
immerhin ein video jetzt und die
arbeiter uns ist gestern noch was
richtig krass es passiert das drehen
wird also das wollen wir heute drehen
das sollte eigentlich in asien
naja zeigt dass apparat im open channel
eine registrierkasse reviews gestern
passiert ist